hey there viewer or listener to people
in the audio version before we get to
tonight's intro and show with Ben
Shapiro Prime Minister Trudeau and
laughing yogi Ramesh I just wanted let
you know that because of your support of
Mudd Club there are some job openings
available new jobs are opening all the
time it's a lot of chatter calm slash
jobs ladder with credit calm slash jobs
where we can go to apply right now
specifically we're looking for two
people a DP / director someone who
really knows their way around a camera
someone who would feel comfortable
creating the kind of parody intro that
you'll see next knows our way around
color correction storyboarding lighting
polishing a professional final product
and a showrunner someone who's sort of
in charge of the master lists to make
sure that the trains run on time
communication takes place there are a
lot of moving parts on this show that we
try to create for you and we of course
want to hire you first people who are
fans of this show almost everyone who
works here came in because they were a
fan and of course qualified experienced
in the entertainment industry or media
is necessary otherwise we'll be
internships opening soon in which
position you will be routinely abused
ladder with credit.com / jobs either
ladder with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walter and hopper
[Music]
look at me talking about social media
back then ain't gonna do you any good
now this is what I'm talking about this
is what I mean when I'm talking about
shadow banning and may corporation
censorship alright their broader idea at
work mainly what you do its
conglomerates say is and isn't allowed
online channel 14 straight hours of
staring and a half Asian water these are
the things you think you ever done that
you can read the guideline follow the
updates it doesn't matter if you follow
their rules or not
YouTube doesn't care you know what they
do they Cheney they find a way to stop
your content not a pervy but right when
you hit that three million was
subscriber mug but see it actually told
this is an unmistakable relief see
because they were afraid and now they
see for the very first time how
conservative late-night show can compete
yeah they saw in the last year they saw
what we were the sketches the references
the whole Lanos cried a production we
were mobile and then just some guy on
him lives on a wife can her some kid
with a few Bank me me we're continuing
to grow
they find a know that it's too late to
stop us see to realize all your life all
your bogus copyright claims off your
false DMCA's all the attempted deep lat
it was all the same say it was all the
same dream a dream that you had trapped
many conservatives and a lot of true a
dream about being a wolf but I'd like
any of the other dream in this one
there's a mob at the end of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
calls the bully Tony with too much dye
in because he has to punch the fist to
signify toughness boom there's a wrist
injury carpal tunnel we don't know I
don't venture Pierrot on the show Prime
Minister Trudeau on the show today do
you'll guess with our laughing yoga in
the show today of course in third chairs
always my favorite lovable drunk
Brautigan phone at Bharati and how are
you Monroe D I'm doing a lot better now
that I have I've got 24 hours of getting
Amy Schumer on my system yes this is she
was a really rough day for people so
members of my club because YouTube
wouldn't let us show it quarterblack
what's up man
FGL Morgan Jr do you enjoy what's one of
the day one of the day is bleep right
away what was that the stag the stack
because your bachelor party went to
Thunder Down Under and on overlays
making sure sources are correct we have
two cute Maddy whereas she's known at
the Young Turks not welcome so a
question of the day today
before him before there's two first one
again we've getting hundreds of letters
and people saying they're not receiving
notifications a lot or even though
you've hit the notification Ballas have
you experienced this comment below you
are our polling data second we'll
beginning into the new movement to do
away with the electoral college this
week we've been talking about democrat
idea do you think is most indicative of
them being sore losers abolishing the
electoral college packing the supreme
court with more justices let me know you
look you were about to say something
there Brautigan right off the tip I know
I was trying to say that I was trying to
think what I thought that the you're
trying to fear Watson in the IQ points
yeah 12 its Amy Schumer I'm like I'm
half can't think and half that's a
that's actually a good point for people
who didn't watch yesterday they right
away we do we do a private test stream
sometimes you know they hit us right
away and remove our ability to stream
the Amy Schumer special so before we
start actually after spending all day
watching reviewing the Amy Schumer
special ammo Club it it's really hard to
find it's like a soul-sucking to find
the funny in anything we all needed to
reset our brain so actually here to help
us with that we have tonight the Guru of
laughter the laughing yogi Ramesh padne
Ramesh padne can you please help us here
today it's okay to choose to laugh just
like me Ramesh pardon me
yogi Thank You father never been happier
for a sponsor Thank You Crowder not only
for the yogi but also that that was
early bit
[Laughter]
chlamydia is on the rise in Quebec my
home promise it's the promise of clinic
Ralphie comes back faster than anywhere
else in Canada it's comes from Montreal
blog some blame the rise of dating apps
and doctors believe that the
availability of anonymous sex makes it
harder to track outbreaks to encourage
Quebecers to get checked the country it
actually established in anonymous hot
bone that's helpful
hello yes STD hotline thanks for calling
me back
yes I am a Canadian citizen that's not
important right now listen
hypothetically speaking let's say
someone were hanging out at say Adonis
in the village how long after that would
it stop burning and weeping it's a good
valid question here's the thing every
time we do that he puts up his hand like
what are you hitchhiking oh no I was I'm
sitting here wondering who would win in
a fight Justin Trudeau orb 800 I'll be
like a double knockout with a limp and
when they were unconscious that goes to
Che Guevera would just mercilessly rape
them here in America going back to
domestic news Alexandria Acacio Cortes
is now blaming her recent approval
rating drop on sexism and racism yeah
recent polling actually has shown that
anti-woman ante minority sentiments are
actually on a steep decline
unfortunately for her the jury's still
out on retards it kind of takes a
nosedive right there at the end yeah
yeah totally see that so when I
do stuff like this and do the research
you have to read through the tweets that
she did there was actually three or four
that she did in a row and right after
that people are saying like praising her
for being articulate like super smart on
the economy are you named a bucket of
saltwater before logging on Twitter
different him they had to she's
intelligent in comparison because yeah
exact content element by the joke
retards yeah you said that word again
we're gonna be crazy
a new report actually just came out that
says daily marijuana use could alright
hold hold your comments or he could be
links to psychosis this comes from India
where you know they use it every day
it's believed that consuming high
potency cannabis on a daily basis
increases the odds of having a psychotic
episode later it goes on to describe the
episodes including detachment syndrome
and intense anxiety and paranoia which
was honest it was surprising to me
because so far we've been seeing great
results using cannabis oil to help with
hoppers chemo treatment I didn't need
all the cheese's did the cops coming
well what oh no just sitting and what
you know you're gonna get hate mail
Rottweilers only do crack anything that
you say against marijuana and you didn't
say it a study said it wasn't you wasn't
on yeah yeah no no it's totally fine how
much creates the greater it and people
already have those right make people
crazy but people who are crazy and don't
know they're crazy
it's like marijuana just it's just the
key or the crazy door yeah crazy door up
those are the people instead of sudden
you'll actually think they're arguing
with you right now right yeah oh why
don't you talk about marijuana I
but you didn't say it cures cancer
you're right
I didn't point for you let's call this
one a washroom
you win you win continue it's opening
the door to the crazy just like that was
that movie with the kids in the Attic
flowers in the attic where the mom might
leave mother I don't someone please
comment I think was flowers in the air
you know or this mom the husband dies
and she takes her kids to her mother's
house or grandma's house and then she
locks them in the attic and the
grandmother Nicole said she didn't know
no you're thinking about the others
thing uh and then she's locked the kids
in the Attic and she never goes from
them one of the kids dies well you never
came for his mother and she said I never
want to do anyway terrible girl no [ __ ]
could be I don't know I think it's
Flowers in the Attic let me know anyways
there's a mystery pooper tormenting
Broadway look at the electoral college
in a second but first the stink bomber
actually says true struck during tryouts
for the new Magic Mike musical where
they use the audition room I like this
guy's a toilet come from the New York
Post it's all fortunately though for the
producers the pilot was the best
performer they saw that day so they did
really know so you have to go
off-broadway definitely dear to go off
off-broadway basically should come off
off off off Broadway
look movie Grand Rapids there's there's
been a bunch of these stories where like
somebody will go and poop in the park
right yeah something like Cooper's have
been I don't have you ever you know one
cares about your vlog is anybody my blog
has anybody ever done this and it's like
you've you ever pooped in a non personal
area okay so it's it's messy right it's
nice it's not fast no how do you what is
not fast like how does the location
determine the speed injection I'm just
saying in normal like it's you're not
gonna do it in three seconds and run
away be a policy you you're gonna get
caught will you do this thing if you do
it's a poop out of animosity yeah with
perfect quick don't I understand that
but sometimes you can't predict how like
if I'm angry I can't predict how the
flow is gonna be okay okay go oh yeah
I'm good I got three sites being about
predictable
you
[Music]
haha that is uh takes a feel hey takes a
mighty fast mundane over there in back
finally news of the day we have this
Japanese man who quote married a
hologram good for you know what I don't
know we don't need the overlay just
here's a clip it's a real thing
[Music]
[Applause]
I must Yeltsin will template then we can
already must give it
I think suicide forest will have a new
visitor Oh
so from the Jakarta posted the beaming
groom a key key key Kondo said I've
never cheated on her I've always been in
love with my cousin unfortunately she
can't say the same as before
Akihiko she had lived a full life yeah
she had really yeah she with her own
kind
Akihiko why can't you see that she needs
to be with her own time send her home
she gets around yes I think she gave
computer virus that's actually why he
died yeah he was supposed to where's
Norton yes and then McAfee had someone
defecate through a hammock so no one saw
that documentary when I was talking my
that notch means they no one had seen
the document or in McAfee no did I had
run occasion well he always President
him and who's the other guy who always
runs for president
wow it's like not Bob Barr I don't know
there's something Sharon Smith president
Mike Mike Grable I have no idea how
you're naming now you're just saying
letters to form names is the insuring
for president this time yeah
again yeah every time I don't know what
go look at the hammock and what he would
do with the hammocks he's messing
through the hammock I don't guess it
makes like Oh actually stop it stop it
that's just because we're talking about
the man doesn't mean that we have to be
truthful about what he does and all of a
spare time just like Gerald on the force
part no no look at his preface this is
before we get to Ben Shapiro I like the
Electoral College loving why just
because it was with Warren and Boehner
work have now come out against the
electoral college here you go we can
have national voting and that means get
rid of the electoral college if we
really want every person to once give
them every reason to vote we got to make
sure their votes count and go to the
candidate of their choosing so I think
there's a lot of wisdom in that it's
something we talked about on the
campaign trail in Texas in that last
Senate race presumptuous on the
candidate of their choosing all right by
the way follow Elizabeth Warren's
Instagram it's the best thing that it
was it yeah you couldn't write satire as
good that's like Oh kids I'm just oh
you're there I didn't see you were there
I'm just gonna get myself a beer Z beer
let me get some powwow Chow on the way
forty-five-year-old she's just awful
here you guys hang out here yeah and
then and then yeah she would here's the
weird thing about the two people who
want to eliminate the electoral college
she's the kind of person who would
accidentally mistake bado because he's
kickflipping as someone who would be a
voting block for her one of the reasons
like people hate it other than the fact
that she's a [ __ ] and kills people
allegedly allegedly was like the
shameless pandering right you know how
do fellow kids and both Warren and
Kamala Harris it's like oh and kirsten
gillibrand that so she knows how to do
it and abortions that's okay really
quick we've done a video before is
rebuttal to Adam ruins everything on the
electoral college you can go watch that
but really quickly there are a lot of
reasons that getting rid of the
electoral college is a bad idea okay
one it's in the Constitution
okay founders intended in its people
have liked the electoral college by the
way is the only area of government which
we aren't appear democracy there are
tons of similar safeguards nakai Supreme
Court justices they're not voted on by a
general populace every
it's two senators regardless of
population we are not a pure democracy
it's a it's a constitutional republic
democracy is mob rule it's important
that people understand that yeah
absolutely and by the way it's something
it's a system that has worked for 242
years so be very careful
142 the Democrats are actually right
here at first personally speaking I
honestly think they should spend as much
time and resources as it takes to
convince 48 other states I thought you
had another stroke for a second but you
made a good point another reason I want
to rattle off through the electoral
college and of course their regional
interests right with on the electoral
college the the concern of course is
about states with low population yeah
all that would matter are the opinions
of people in urban areas okay that's
that's really wouldn't they tend to have
different views than people in suburban
areas right right Leslie different views
which is actually a major problem we
have in New York this you have basically
Manhattan and Brooklyn making decisions
for all of upstate yeah right they have
no saying well and that's a good example
entry swing states are actually they're
more transient than large cities okay
who would you rather have a
disproportionate amount of power of the
American electorate states like Ohio
Florida Pennsylvania or at one point
Texas now Michigan I think Wisconsin
places that were never considered to be
swing states or only four or five major
cities which by the way they have
disproportionate amounts of crime
poverty take your crappy pick most
popular will you just talk about New
York or Los New York Los Angeles Chicago
or a handful of cities take New York
City and Amazon right yeah they kicked
out Amazon just a few pretty then kicked
it out free money now apply that to
those people being able to determine
that Amazon can't be in any state even a
state even five states over because
Cortez has an opinion another example
would be energy people in New York and
Los Angeles should be voting to take
away tens of thousands of clean coal
jobs or renewable resource jobs and I
know you don't think those are noble
resources but thank God for fracking
because you have an opinion in a major
city you should determine how everybody
else lives across the country that's why
the electoral college exists by the way
another interesting thing the Democrats
have their own electoral college yeah
which is which is by the way far worse
every time they're the only ones who
have super-delegates which I don't
really understand
parallel use gives a lot of power
disproportionately to Apple that's how
that is my delegates and Hillary
actually won the popular vote into 2008
primaries not Barack Obama so this is
just another example of Democrats
wanting others to play by different
rules than they do
yeah poor Hillary right she gets beat
with super-delegates and then she gets
beat by the second worst candidate ever
Duran you just can't catch a break of
your hair and you got beat n by grammar
lesson suicide after the 2008 primaries
what what she tends to kill someone just
everyone here is is that it's it's a
change based on a disingenuous argument
okay Democrats just want to do away with
the electoral college because they think
will benefit them why because right now
they don't like the rules yeah
if you don't buddy just look at the how
the headlines of James from your year in
what they want and it's not just the
Electoral College of Democrats want to
change this is a pattern let me go
through a few examples we want to know
that is your favorite to filibuster yep
Democrats already ditched to filibuster
in the Senate they changed the rules
because they thought it would benefit
them here's something that's really
painful for both conservatives and
Democrats to admit Mitch McConnell was
right when he warned that they would
regret it look here is your oracle if
you want to play games that get another
precedent that you'll no doubt come to
regret
say to my friends on the other side of
the aisle you'll regret this and you may
regret it a lot sooner than you think
and I really really want him to be wrong
[Laughter]
was easy to be confined you don't want
to say easily confirmed but more easily
confirmed then you look how far they go
to try and stop the confirmation because
the end of the filibuster right exactly
anyway if they had had it they would
have been able to probably at least
postpone it for a while but this was one
of the most horrible decisions I've ever
seen Congress make you took out one of
the things that was there as a
protection to make sure that the
minority had a voice when something was
being rammed down their throats and a
way to make sure that they could
hopefully stop something or at least
change people's mind right and now
nobody's gonna put it back in right I
think that's a problem Republicans
missed an opportunity and women
but Democrats don't care why now they
just want to change the rules again how
by now adding seats to the Supreme Court
before I move on to that hit the
notification bell let me know if you're
receiving notifications if you're
subscribed because apparently a lot of
you aren't so please bookmark the page
join my club that compliment subscribe
on iTunes for the audio version we don't
know how much longer we're gonna be here
we certainly can't upload our Amy
Schumer reviews okay so now you have
bado or as we know robert Francis
O'Rourke and other Democrats have been
pitching adding a bunch of seats to the
Supreme Court even doing away with
things like term limits it you don't
take my word for it
assume who proposed do you want five
Democrat justices and five Republican
justices in those ten then choose
another five justices between them do we
add justices on that court in another
way do we set term limits for those
justices so there's some predictability
all the justices I like you less than
Drake that's how you know there's a very
very white show yeah by the way if you
want to apply to work here we could
really use a black I mean another 3/4 of
a lot yeah come on
least more than half like that'll I mean
lock your doors
when you've broke through the wrong area
of town long history one impact courts
right this goes back to FDR he wasn't
able to do it but he wanted to do it
yeah this is how it works with Democrats
I mean I'm rejoining the court yeah just
wait till your novice then just add a
bunch of seeds to get a majority and
just appoint you guys that's what's
crazy to me is they constantly whine
about Donald Trump about President Trump
eroding political norms with his mean
tweets they're the ones actually trying
to undermine the foundations of our
government from the people who create
and just a quick question here like
we're talking about a court with judges
these are supposed to be some of the
most fair-minded judges in all of the
land some of the most educated people
that we can possibly find that can put
on blinders and judge a case on its
merits alone and we're talking about
Republican and Democrat judges I think
we've missed the boat here the Supreme
Court is not supposed to be people that
have bias opposed to be people that view
the law and that's it but it never fails
where are you gonna find somebody no I'm
not sure another liberal
we're gonna have to look in some coffee
house where someone calls themself if
you're gonna you know you're as judges
the people who up until Election Day
between Donald Trump Hillary don't sale
work quite sure yet well I'm not saying
of mine you can maybe convince me my
vote to the table what are you gonna
give you want that personal trophy wait
I don't want that person what I'm saying
is you can be a Republican or a Democrat
but the second you put on that robe and
you sit on that bench you have to put
that aside and you have to make a fair -
smart and we don't we don't look at the
Supreme Court like that all i care is
that you're a rapist and you sail
through i mean we could do that or
democrats can get the idea of more
justices and in the public spear so
people actually agree with it you see so
here I said spear when it's like an H
all right continue with this point where
we are waiting with bated breath yes
they can make they can make it really
popular Donald Trump can win and then he
can add five judges yeah you know why
don't you start adding judges now tweet
that Donald Trump I think we should add
a hundred million judges no palette wah
BAE dal is so eat with reverse
psychology it was a skateboarding like
what I want the electoral college now
this is another example where they just
want to change the rules the voting age
right now Pelosi just just just said but
she's always been for lowering the
voting age to wait for it 16 I myself
have always been for lowering the voting
the voting age to social habits I think
it's really important to capture the
boating even in high school when they're
interested to be able to vote by the way
your sweet 16 was centuries ago idea
runs contrary to this they've campaigned
for raising gun ownership from 18 to 21
yeah so you aren't responsible enough to
own a tool for hunting at 18 but you
should be able to vote in someone who's
willing to kick out Amazon five states
away and completely kill your economy
but when's the last time you had a
conversation with a 16 year old they
don't
I'm sorry 16 year olds can be smart most
of the time you don't know anything and
specifically you don't know anything
about how the world works
yeah right you tend to be very liberal
when you're in heist
if you have any political leaning at all
and then when you actually get out in
the world and have a job you're like oh
crap conservatives the way to go
free-market love it well then you don't
you know so I am not letting I'm sorry I
don't want anybody by the way your
rhetorical question of when was last
time you spoke with a 16 year old was
answered by pedophiles everywhere the
comment reduction its salon right now
there's usually not a lot of
conversation going on over struck
Gerald's point do they even teach you as
history when you're 16 in the first
place well that was that was a junior
class yeah I didn't learn US history at
all because I was raised in Canada so
what I did during history class was fall
asleep the number four it's incredibly
boring
we just said you're in Canada what you
said uncle uncle we put your queen and
her money no we kind of glossing the
Constitution no let's go with that
ultimately the Democrat they're
constantly in favor of changing the
rules because they don't even them up
they don't honor the most foundational
rulebook for the country the
Constitution we know they're openly
against the Second Amendment right yeah
even openly calling for its repeal and
they'll say no they're not if you talk
about a mandatory buyback like in
Australia
yeah you're basically advocating for
repealing a second government and by the
way continue they call for more laws
against hate speech which would
essentially repeal the First Amendment
it doesn't stop there some of them
completely want to actually abolish the
Senate this is something that's a ground
floated this is again it's just it's a
constant changing of rules to undermine
the constitutional republic that is
United States and the electoral cause
it's just one in a long line of stupid
ideas yeah and then you put out
misinformation about the second
amendment that it doesn't actually say
that you can have arms it says you can
be a part of a militia you do it on
purpose do you know how easy it is to
screw this up by the way I don't think
people understand that point it is
incredibly easy to mess up something
that is working right you don't have to
try very very hard to do that to get it
to go from 95 to say 98 is incredibly
difficult without screwing it up it's
working really well okay yeah you can
eff it up so fast stop right stop trying
to change it and they're doing it just
for short it's not they don't understand
that they if they do with like torille
college how the election would be
decided if someone doesn't know the
majority of the vote it's not a
plurality it's a majority of the vote
and then these are the same people who
[ __ ] about the chief woody system and
press how do you what is he's gonna
happen with the Electoral College if we
have a situation like Canada where
someone can win with 30-something
percent of the vote exactly do you know
is going to be
I just do me a favor accuracy think two
or three steps down the line Democrats
just do me a quick favor think two or
three moves down and go oh yeah that's a
really bad idea let's let's walk it back
no think it's a bad idea as long as it
serves them in the moment and this is no
politician should be doing this whether
it's Donald Trump or Elizabeth Warren or
paedo you should not be selling out to
futures of American citizens to pay out
voters now right that's the issue here
and this is what I know people attend I
don't like labels you know what I'm okay
I'm okay with the label conservative I'm
okay this is what separates
conservatives from liberals or leftist
or progressive okay there's proof for
you that we're different they call
themselves liberals hey call themselves
progressives they're the ones switching
the labels to mean different things over
time we've pretty much always called
ourselves conservatives it's not really
changed our views have been pretty
consistent
there's never are people try to say well
what about conservatives in free speech
okay sure there might have been a couple
of Republicans along with tipper gore
who wanted to put warning labels on CDs
but if you look at the mainstream
conservative interpretation of the
Constitution on court it really it
really hasn't changed all that much
pretty consistent no this is something
else this is something that they try to
do as a trump card is what about the
fact that conservatives are racist like
haven't you changed the party you flip
because blur stuff I'm not gonna let you
do it
okay okay check okay John Oliver I'm not
gonna let you say well what about the
feta no we're not racist we've never
been the party of racism do you mean the
conservative interpretation the platform
that interpreted the Constitution in
that no man has a right to own another
man sign into law by Abraham Lincoln
those racist reporters switched what are
you talking about Strom Thurmond get the
hell out of here we if we want to have
an honest conversation about the state
of our country and you have a problems
the Electoral College
okay fine but don't go trying to change
the rulebook every time an election
doesn't go your way and then turn around
and tell us about the erosion of our
American values because we don't want to
let some caravan from a craphole country
in okay we just don't want you to be
chastising us I hope I've clarified my
point Ben Shapiro after this yes
[Music]
history is gonna change this
[Music]
it's beginning right there like he's
starting it going it is transitional
yeah
but a week away from get is tipped off
stupid little pieces
[Music]
people believe just failed in the studio
[Music]
lotta Wakata shop comm supports babies
we don't kill them
so purchase your baby onesie it louder
with Photoshop comm today now for trick
tips with bado member when cops pull you
over you can refuse the breathalyzer
just say to the cop oh my God look at
that thing then run away for the next 20
you don't be obeyed Oh join my club for
$99 a year 69 dollars a year for
students veterans or active military
[Music]
[Music]
it's a stick-up apparently according to
this song hey speaking of things up you
know our next guest will never look me
in the skype right before the show he's
always looking down so you know what
been dismissed look at my son poison
look at this
look at it at been should be that
simplify lit on a daily wire Ben Shapiro
my wife applied my suntan lotion I'm
gonna take off my pants and show you my
upper thighs Ben know you've done that
before on my show this wasn't those were
ranger panties and by the way I owe you
a pair have you ever gotten so sunburned
that you wanted to throw up
uh not that I wanted to throw up that's
the new one but you get queasy you get
really queasy and I don't know that was
heat stroke or sudden poisoning but my
wife got and I got into a hell of an
argument because she said she didn't
trust me with Sun lotion she applied it
look Wow Wow well well done by your wife
I mean yeah you know what as a man who's
watched you be waterboarded enjoyed it
thoroughly
thanks for wife I appreciate it you know
what if it was her lying low and there's
something that I did that aggravated her
months back and this was I would just
have to give that one to her I'm just
gonna have to give it to her
okay so Ben you have a new book out
right now I want to show this right it's
the right side of history how reason and
moral purpose made the great west it's
going to be released I guess it was
released on Tuesday March 19th so before
we get to that I want to talk with you
about this has been kind of making the
rounds quite a bit you know the Senate
passed a bill that would allow states to
punish businesses that take part in
Israel boycotts right that's kind of how
it's been sort of surmised about Libya
plays a big role in this what's your
position on this is someone obviously
who both of us support Israel's right to
exist but also the ability for
businesses to practice business freely
100% well the here's what the bill
actually does so the what the bill
actually does it doesn't punish
businesses that boycott Israel what it
says is that the state will not contract
with businesses the boycott Israel so
there are plenty of laws like this that
are on the books with regard to for
example racial discrimination there are
a lot of but laws on the books like this
with regard to anti-discrimination in in
LGBT communities this is particularly
true in places like California and New
York where if you are a government age
so you can't do business with a business
that is refusing to do business with
black people for example so this is not
the state going out of its way to
quote-unquote punish people who are
anti-israel I mean the state doesn't owe
you a contract it's the state deciding
which businesses it will do business
with to be honest with you I'm somewhat
indifferent on the law I don't think
it's a violation of the First Amendment
at the same time I generally am NOT a
huge fan of the government you know
conditioning its contracts with people
on the political views of those
businesses and I think that's it's
generally a mistake so I'm not a huge
detractor of this particular bill I'm
also not a huge advocate for this
particular bill but I think it's
important to be a kerub out what the
bill does and it's not you know forcing
businesses not to be Pro BDS if they
want to be Pro BDS they can be Pro BDS
they just can't do business with the
state right yeah I think that's
important to note and there have been a
lot of people who've taken this out of
context and make it seem as though
basically they're banning businesses who
boycott Israel we're sort of getting
into the business of kind of like no bid
contracts really talking about companies
having contracts with the government
this changes the working relationship
quite a bit speaking of the speaking of
Israel this week not a lot of coverage
because it happened I believe right
before New Zealand I don't know the
final tally several rockets launched
from Gaza into Tel Aviv you can see the
footage of it being stopped by the Iron
Dome well how do you how do you see this
moving forward from here and how would
you like to see this moving forward
again the Rockets yeah I mean there was
no coverage of the Rockets there's no
coverage of another terror attack in
which father of 12 was was murdered in
Israel 47 year old rabbis father of 12
these sorts of attacks are just
completely ignored by the world media
because when it's Israel involved then
we pretend that Israel is not a member
of the Western coalition and terror
attacks against Israelis are simply
chalked up to anti-israel sentiment as
opposed to anti-jewish sentiment firing
rockets into the middle of Tel Aviv
which is a civilian area that is not in
quote the West Bank or in the Gaza Strip
obviously is pretty good indicator that
maybe Hamas just wants to destroy Israel
other good indicators include their
charter in which they say they want to
destroy Israel and all of their
propaganda in which they say they want
to destroy Israel and the fact that
they've built terror tunnels instead of
providing food for their people the
other uncovered story from the Gaza
Strip is that Hamas is
its own citizens in in the Gaza Strip
seven people were shot this week by
Hamas in the streets and they're
arresting all the dissidents the media
don't ever find any of this stuff
newsworthy they find it newsworthy when
Israel fights back when Israel goes in
and targets Hamas right when Israel hits
a school the Colossus using as a
military base for example then that
becomes a world story but but firing
rockets into the middle of civilian
areas and the biggest city in Israel let
me ask you this thanks for shutting your
phone off mr. Shapiro you know what you
know what crowd I know you're so good
when you're far too busy for us Gentiles
and our non hatted skulls here's the
thing what you just mentioned I agree
with you but even if there's a schism
where a lot of people think oh man
Israel just gets all the media coverage
because the media is run by the run by
Jewish executives and so all of these
people support Israel everyone the
entertainment industry and then people
who are pro-israel say well now listen
they're always sympathizing with
Palestine they're not covering the
Rockets being launched it seems as
though both sides have really dug in
their heels and see the media is either
being overtly Pro Jewish pro-israel or
completely amt Israel why do you think
that is because you have to be out of
your mind to believe that the media are
overtly pro-israel I mean CNN III went
on CNN in 2014 and I said that they were
essentially an outlet for Hamas I mean
the the the CNN's coverage of these
sorts of conflicts is inevitably geared
toward Israel as the aggressor because
the left-wing narrative is that Israel
is the bad guy in this in this
particular conflict for the same reason
that that rich people are generally seen
as the bad guys in in various conflicts
around the world
the latter all Disney films left largely
says whenever there's someone successful
and unsuccessful must be because the
successful person somehow hurt the
unsuccessful person and they see that
same conflict playing out in Israel
Israel is successful it is very
economically prosperous society has a
lot of Technology has a very powerful
military and so the narrative is that
that must be because they have
disadvantage the Palestinians Israel has
been trying desperately to hand over
control of the West Bank and the Gaza
Strip to the Palestinians for
legitimately decades at this point they
did hand over full control of the Gaza
Strip to the Palestinians in 2005
remember wrong Palestinians promptly
burned down all the green houses in
electrical mosque so it's worked out
fantastic and the charger is key you
know if you sign up for iTunes and if
you read the agreement it says by the
way we're also going to kill your wife
and family
hold on a second this seems odd to put
in the agreement seems
you want me to gloss over that one Tim
Apple let me ask you I said Tim Cook
there's a video I said Tim Cook why lie
about this it's just a flub that doesn't
matter
final question though this is one thing
as someone who you know has vehemently
defended Israel's right to exist do you
see it as a problem or a lot of
detractors point to an inconsistency in
them being sort of allies with Saudi
Arabia one of the biggest funders of
terrorism I understand the geopolitics
as it relates to Iran as it relates to
the conflicts over there and they need
some kind of protection that being said
the Saudi Arabia relationships both with
the United States government and Israeli
government doesn't sit well with a lot
of people what about yourself well in an
ideal world obviously wouldn't be allied
with any bad governments the reality of
the world as president Trump has
correctly stated is that very often
you're allied with bad governments
against worst governments and that's
certainly the case with both the United
States his relationship with Saudi
Arabia and now the Israeli relationship
with Saudi Arabia you don't
unfortunately get to pick all of your
allies when it comes to world politics
were that the case then it would've been
very difficult to side with Stalin said
if you´d Hitler during World War two
you're constantly having to make choices
about which people are worthy of siding
with in order to stop worse people and I
see that less as inconsistency and more
is just the realities on the ground
that's that's just a truism of politics
generally but we can agree Saudi Arabian
government kind of dicks awful coming on
because if I say this people look you're
paid by big Shapiro my name I'm not
Jewish I just think that this stuff is a
pretty reasonable right to exist they
have rockets going into there there are
their main city there from this trip by
the way take the strip turn it into a
strip mall for all I care so your book
right side of history wouldn't that be
great if Donald Trump could go in and
call it Trump Gaza Strip ball it would
sell like hot cash I don't want to go
there nobody wants to go to strip malls
but I'd go to that strip mall
especially sits at under the Iron Dome
so right side of history the book was
released this week what tell us give us
a briefer on this and why you think it's
important for everyone to read your book
you've talked about this and obviously
that's a good play everyone needs to
read my book but you've talked about
specifically whether they agree with you
politically ideologically or not how why
is this book different in that sense
well what the book basically is about is
why we're so angry at each other we live
in the freest
prosperous civilization in the history
of the world and it is not closed and
yet we are supremely pissed at each
other and that is because in my view we
have forgotten the sort of ties that
bind us together and those are ties that
have a long history a 3,000 year history
going back through Sinai through the
through the Sermon on the Mount and
including Greek thought as well this can
a merger of judeo-christian values and
Greek reason that that interplay created
the West and created all the values that
we like today so if you like science if
you like technology if you're a big fan
of free speech if you are a big fan of
living in a democracy all of these
concepts come out of the West they don't
come out of anywhere else and so we have
to try and reexamine why it is that
these concepts came out of the West and
whether those concepts are rooted in
something deeper and more valuable and
that we can't just discard I think that
we sort of want to take the gains of
Western civilization while ignoring the
roots of Western civilization or even
fighting against those roots and I don't
think you can do that I don't think that
you can fight judeo-christian values and
at the same time talk about how you want
to maintain all of the prosperity
equality and freedom of Western
civilization you can't you can't remove
the foundation from a building and
expect the facade to stand no I think
that's a good point but you just talked
about how its kind of we're supremely
pissed off at each other and examining
why well let me just say this I I always
talk about this I don't believe in
finding common ground if there's the
truth and the truth does not find itself
in the common ground people just heard
you say that about Western civilization
people will read this book and they will
be supremely pissed off so are you by
default
adding to the polarization in simply
pointing out the truth
that's my issue or you have a lot people
who shall remain nameless who go out and
go we're just gonna build bridges well
okay good example I can't build a bridge
with Hamas if and their charters to blow
me up right I mean then the book is also
a clarification obviously and there is a
view of Western civilization the Western
civilization is inherently bad I hope
that the book convinces people the
Western civilization is not inherently
bad but if it's your view that Western
civilization is all about racism sexism
bigotry homophobia and that all of those
things can only be torn out by removing
Western civilization at its root and
replacing it with some sort of new
socialist utopia or replacing it with
tribal intersectionality if that's your
view well then let's clarify that view
and let's have that argument because I
think your argument sucks but the the
again the idea here is that America was
based in certain values that are pretty
much
our founding documents we haven't always
lived up to those values obviously
sometimes we don't live up to those
values today but to suggest that
America's values are about the evils
rather than about the goods is to ignore
the fact that the goods that have been
produced by the West are uniquely
Western and the evils that the West has
produced are not unique to the West at
all they've been universal in virtually
every human society that's a very good
point yeah the virtues here are pretty
unique to the West that's one thing also
when you deal with moral relativists who
or atheist hardcore atheists you say
well if I need a God to tell me not to
kill somebody then I'm just crazy and
that God is great well okay hold on a
second what about a god that tell you to
be merciful not all societies valued
mercy particularly not until modern
Christendom what about a God that tells
you to not cheat on your wife what about
a God who tells you to love your wife
and speak to her tenderly these are not
Universal values there are certain
values that we see in the West
particularly in the United States that
have not been embedded in other
societies that do come directly from
judeo-christian principles and it's
always it's always interesting to me
that the hardcore atheist take the
extreme arguments I will act every
society knows that killing is wrong even
if we take that example not all
societies agree with that you look at
Native Americans they didn't have a
concept of personal property and so you
come home your was gone because it
wasn't technically yours you know this
is these are things that people don't
think about I'm sure the fact is that
even if you take the example of murder
it is true that virtually every society
has taboo against murder that does not
mean that the the law extends to people
beyond your tribe so it's very easy to
say yeah you're not allowed to murder
people who are inside our tribe like
inside this this camp right here but
over there those guys though those
aren't humans over there and also if you
happen to be a very powerful person you
do have the right to kill somebody who's
below you on the social scale you do
have the right to to kill people who are
more weak and more vulnerable so to
suggest that a universal taboo against
murder is not is not embedded in the
Bible in a different way than its
embedded in pagan civilizations is to
ignore the fact that child sacrifice was
a regular thing and a lot of pagan
civilizations right or Kony I said that
movie taking the child soldiers remember
that remember Kony know the big
documented Kony was his war you remember
that quarter backyard I was actually
wrong there's a campaign and then the
guy who made it went on a like a Martin
Lawrence style bender in LA he was
snorting coke and he was naked I think
on Sunset Boulevard and this window leer
direction I do
listen.you you say you saw the ride you
bought a ticket anyway mmm all right
look at the final question here Ben
because this has been an entirely
reasonable interview and I want some
people pissed off with both you and
myself because it's always what happens
after these are you given a report card
and Donald Trump here especially as
we're looking at the DNC candidates
coming up what would you give him
overall what would you do you think he
wins in 2020 you know I think that the I
hate to hedge bets but I didn't hedge my
bets in the last election cycle man I
lost lots of money you did so when it's
when it comes to you know how President
Trump is going to do in this election
cycle it's almost entirely dependent on
two factors can he shot his face well
sounds come out can he stop his tweeting
thumbs and also will the Democrats
nominate somebody completely loony or
will they try to go toward the more
electable direction and nominate someone
who's half loony like Joe Biden or are
they going to go completely bat bleep
and nominate you know Bernie Sanders is
that is that the way they go so if
President Trump could shut up and allow
the focus to be on Democrats I would say
that he has a better than 50% chance of
being reelected you know if however he
continues to do what he's doing and
drive away suburban women he lost the
popular vote by two and a half million
votes last time he ran the narrowest
gauntlet American history he won the
three key states by combined to 80
thousand votes who own fuel a ballute
votes in Wisconsin then Mitt Romney won
in Wisconsin the real story of 2016 is
nobody showed up to vote for Hillary
Clinton number one cuz they didn't like
her at number two because they figured
she was going to win that same
phenomenon is not going to take place
again Democrats are going to show up
they're gonna show up in big numbers so
president Trump's best bet here he's not
going to convince people that he's a
wonderful human being because people
think what they think about him already
right the best bet here is just shut up
well the reason for him shutting up what
all is more helpful to him is because
the economy is doing so well the New
York Times I'm trying to find excuses as
to why it works and attributed to Obama
if he can just be silent and direct
people toward his record on the economy
and then say hey by the way now Kamala
Harris and she's saying whatever Kamala
Harris says or by the way here's a
lizard huge Elizabeth Ward did Sigrid
have Fudd that's all he needs to do and
he wins I agree if he could get out it's
like a race to the bottom if you can get
out of his own way this should be very
winnable because of the economy if they
run Joe Biden I don't think it matters
as long as Donald Trump is just a little
bit more disciplined but I don't think
they can run
I think is gonna be Kamala Harris I
think it's gonna be the double triple
minority factor and maybe they'll put
bado on there because I don't know he's
a weiner they need a weirdo who tries to
feed his wife who is avocado or
something what is that story No did you
see the story I was a Washington Post
story about him and his wife and
normally I don't care about the spouses
of candidates but the story is mostly
about how he's a weirdo how he likes to
prank his wife and apparently he took
like one of his kids diaper diaper turds
and put it in a bowl and told her that
it was avocado and also in the last few
months apparently he went to New Mexico
and he ate dirt I'm not kidding you it
says this in the story like to recover
from his loss to Ted Cruz he ate he was
supposed to restore sustenance to him he
went in he ate dirt no that was just a
spin on the story he lost a bet and Ted
Cruz was making him eat the dirt going
now yeah
that's right eco like I don't know why
sounds like George Bush sees the poo
thing goes that could you can die that's
just who could have killed it like
cinnamon challenge it's off the
Millennials I mean that the substituting
poo for avocado that'll piss off all
Judy not what's he gonna do next time
he's gonna add ways gonna take a rabbit
poop to substitute for single origin
coffee and just put it in a coffee house
to a pour-over alright the book is when
we share the title uh the right side of
history how reason and moral purpose
made the Great West the show is bench
Bureau show on daily wire of course he's
the editor in chief of Daily wire all
right mr. bet Daly why I appreciate it
you must go catch you later
see ya wrapping it I
[Applause]
[Music]
your jungler
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I really need work we got
wherever the
that's how you run the global economy
[Music]
our technological advancement as a
society has outpaced
our system for handling finite resources
because now we are approaching
approaching infinite resources nailed it
and like really good at this stuff
I run this board and the boss what if I
ran for president I'd be like a super
genius president I'd be like one of
those baby geniuses from the movie
president
if there's a sale in forever 21 join my
club today only $99 a year $69 for
students veterans or active military
[Music]
that's an old favorite people were audio
listeners only from you that's the Greg
Louganis turning did I see platform
diver who hit his back back of his head
on the board and spilled a jelly Olympic
pool and he was played by Louie Diamond
Phillips I believe I believe it was
played by Ludo infamously might've been
played by a Mario Lopez and the
made-for-tv film point is his life is
not very good yeah and I was young I
remember I read the story in Sports
Illustrated for kids which just tells
you how horribly inappropriate that
magazine was and I confuse Greg Louganis
I thought Lou Gehrig's disease was named
for the guy who had AIDS who hit his
head that guy was pretty bad yeah I know
it's obviously I was incorrect okay
because I heard about Greg Louganis
before locater thank you so much to Ben
Shapiro yeah I really appreciate him
being on the show speaking of eights by
the way they're gonna be age walks going
on across the country this weekend and
so you know who knows maybe someone will
show up big shows next week we're
looking forward to it hey one thing I
know this is a segment that we often do
I wanted to talk with you guys about a
couple of things today I know I'm not
supposed to read the comment sections
and I usually don't on social media
obviously people who who are my club
members that's a little bit different we
can interact with people there but that
2q Matic can you bring up the overlay
here this is one thing that I did see
recently in the Amy Schumer special this
person said I would love to join but
I've been taking care of my mom for the
last few years two weeks ago informed us
that she only has three to six months
left COPD sucks I'll eventually join us
support them meaning us but for this
time YouTube will have to suffice and
this other person just user net we've
eliminated any private info here though
they did post it on YouTube
ill-advised god bless you I'd like to
send you the money to sign up for mug
club and if you want read the rest these
comments can bring it down to keeping
adding people oh I can see if you're
listening to audio version I encourage
you to go watch the video first off
we're gonna get you we appreciate that
our fans are trying to support each
other we're gonna get you obviously
hooked up with with Michael we'll make
sure we'll find your email will track
you down and we'll make sure that you're
taking care we really appreciate the
sentiment but seeing our fans you act
that way knowing that that that is true
it's indicative of the bulk of you who
tuned in to this show it really does you
know I know as I get older it sounds but
it really does warm my heart I think it
warms all of our cockles yeah you
shouldn't use that term but I used it
anyway
well you should be you should be but not
because of that so two things I wanted
to talk about today the first thing is
the steaming others for serving other
people first so let me tell you the
story this last weekend I went to
Florida with my wife to visit the
in-laws letmein loss great great people
I'm very fortunate in that respect the
first day we were fighting quite a bit
arguing quite a bit and this tends to I
don't know if you've noticed it's the
first day of vacation if this tends to
happen the first day of vacation like
when I my wife and I when we used to
live in different states before we were
married the first day we would always be
arguing and usually the last day and I
think it's because of one brace but
women beings are selfish and so you have
your way of doing things or your
expectations and then you're locked in a
room with someone basically or a tube in
the sky and you're staying in the same
room and your in-laws apartments and you
find out that you really can't do things
the way that you've been wanting to do
them in the next I will since the next
two days and our trip we're great
because we consciously decided that
rather than push and pull and bump heads
that we would serve each other first and
this is a challenge I would like to
issue to everyone out there because I we
get a lot of life advice questions we do
those segments behind that they pay well
I want to challenge you from one week
one week to focus on serving other
people and that brings me to my second
point and one that I think might be a
little bit uncomfortable for a lot of
people serving others first thing of
others first it also gets you out of the
rhythm that we all fall into of getting
what we deserve you can call it
entitlement we all feel it to a certain
degree we're also focused on getting
what we deserve on what we rightfully
have coming to us only have you ever
actually thought about that there were
other comments on the Amy Schumer
special teaser which I'll be honest
about piss me off a little bit people
complaining about the fact that mug club
exists right because why can't you just
upload it all for free I'm not paying
for I'm not paying for Michael I don't
have the money and when I read that I
got pissed for a few reasons
some are valid and I realized some of
them are I own issues valid ones for
example we literally couldn't upload
yesterday's Amy Shanno review we test it
on a private stream YouTube immediately
struck the video and revoked this
private channels live-streaming
privileges it's not just about D
monetization anymore it's outright
banning sometimes we simply can't get to
show up you saw it with the Oscars
the trailer itself demonetised ii it was
upright it's worse than that so they
just don't let you upload the review yes
it's it's it's not even just about you
not receiving notifications even though
you opted in two three four or five
times some of you out there so please
bookmark the page and keep checking in
sometimes we just can't do another thing
we've always created exclusive content
like The Daily Show for people who are
mockolate members because we've wanted
to provide everyone with more free
content mud clip is the only one anyone
here survives so that's why not
everything goes up for free and
sometimes I'll read these comments and I
think well you know what maybe you know
maybe you don't deserve this show May if
you don't join my club this show might
go away if you're not willing to step up
the show will go away forever you'll log
into your Facebook and that's what you
deserve but if I'm being honest neither
do i I don't deserve this I don't
deserve this show I don't deserve for
the I don't serve the many of you out
there to give me your hard earned money
so that I and everyone here can continue
to create and perform this show for you
you know sometimes this show is hard
sometimes yeah people burn out sometimes
you run into health issues but oh my god
I don't deserve to get up every day and
work sure maybe 10 14 hours on creating
something but creating something that
people love for people who love me who
love this show the people you who've
created this platform who've made this
channel the number one conservative
channel in the history of YouTube why am
i think about this I'm reading the
comment that's why you don't read the
comment section I am I getting pissed
because some people want to rip our
content for free I don't deserve any of
this it's a blessing and when I think
about what I deserve have you ever
really thought about that I mean really
thought about it when I think about it
I'll tell you I'll be scary when I think
of throughout my life the mistakes I
make the people of hurt whether on
purpose or by accident the ripple effect
some of my misdeeds may have created
when I add it all up I really want what
I deserve
do you do any of us and yeah listen to
you the guy girl or Z who doesn't want
to support the show you do you deserve
for this show to go away you deserve to
log into your YouTube account and go oh
it's completely gone I never get to
watch it again but you won't that's not
good you know why because of great
because of the grace of other people
because other people have paid the bill
for you and just like you saw in that
comment earlier it's from someone who's
willing to help another person out my
point is since none of us really want to
get what we actually deserve any of us
we all like to think about what we've
earned to what we're entitled little
even sometimes a little Joy's in life
that we deserve about treating yourself
but what about that there's a go both
ways what about the justice what about
the punishment you think about what you
deserve there you know what most if not
all of us have never had to truly bear
the brunt of what we deserve and the
only reason we don't is because of grace
now listen I'm a Christian okay so I
believe and I'm thankful for God's grace
when it comes to the ultimate justice
and Punishment but let's take it out of
the medical metaphysical sense here okay
and your day-to-day you don't receive
what you truly deserve often only
through the grace of others usually by
many others who lift your burdens who
serve your needs and you probably don't
even recognize it I know most of us
certainly don't appreciate it it's why I
see entitlement mindsets is so
pervasively evil you don't deserve I
mean hard truth here you don't deserve
your job you have won by the grace of
someone else who created a product which
stems from the grace of someone else who
created a company which tends on the
grace of someone to create an industry
which stems from the grace of someone
who graced the world with an idea you
don't deserve you don't you do not
deserve health care or an average life
expectancy that's 20 to 30 years longer
than your great-grandfather you receive
it by the grace of someone else who is
providing the procedure that you need or
the grace of someone who pioneered
modern medicine the grace of someone who
took a risk that you yourself would
likely probably never be willing to take
and I know right now we're talking about
money exchanging hands and so people
will light up the comment section saying
well it's not by grace it's a profit
motive but that's not entirely true and
by the way you're missing the point
either way let's go smaller with it you
don't deserve that coffee your wife or
your husband maybe this morning you
often you don't deserve then wavering
love or support that they give you you
receive it through grace it's for the
same simple concept by the way that
mandated entitlements destroy a nation
take the concept let's take the concept
of universal income how does think about
why do I hate this so
it's predicated on the idea that you
deserve the right to a basic universal
income regardless of worker ability
sounds good
but has it work it only works by the
grace of others by the grace of others
who did the work and who had their
spoils taken from them at gunpoint
nothing that you think you deserve when
you trace it back far enough can stem
from anything other than the grace of
someone else and this brings me back to
my first point just I think entitlement
robs people of their spirit of their
soul your own mindset of entitlement of
what you deserve
Rob's you of truly living a fulfilling
life don't believe me try this for a
week
write this down okay take some grab a
pen and paper if you're listening on the
audio version all of next week live your
life day-to-day to bestow grace upon and
serve others for the whole week in other
words this week first thing when you
wake up think of how you can serve
people you love the most what do you
what do you usually do grab yourself a
cup of coffee go for a job nope not this
week you're going to bring your wife a
cup of coffee you're going to get up
earlier and help prepare your husband so
that he can go for a jog before work if
you find yourself getting frustrated
with things not going your way
okay stop and ask yourself why your wife
your husband your dad your mom whoever
it is the next guy down the line might
be frustrated and helped him to pave his
way
do you often find yourself getting sad
depressed even talked about this I've
struggled with it find someone else
who's even more set someone who has even
more of a reason to be depressed you
know they're there cheer them up one
week that's what I'm asking you to do
for one week I want you to flip the
switch on the day-to-day of making sure
that you get what you deserve and make
sure that you are living a life to serve
others one week do that every waking
moment tell me doesn't change your life
tell me doesn't change your entire
perspective comment let me know the fact
is this if for the people out there who
commented on this if you don't join my
club and support this program listen you
you don't deserve this show anything
that you enjoy is enjoyed by the grace
of others who paid the bill just as
certainly I don't deserve your support I
don't you pay my bills you pay all of
our bills
you feed all of our families I don't
deserve the blessing that is the ability
to employ a dozen people and to create
this show for you every day
I received support by your grace and I
try to serve you as best as I can every
day and you know what I hope will be
around here another decade from now able
to serve you through your grace and more
importantly I really want to see more of
what I saw in that comment section of
people helping someone else out more of
you mug club or subscriber supporters
bestowing grace on each other because
you know what that's what makes you
different from a lot of these other
channels it's not about what you deserve
it's about what you give one week use
that comment as a model try it out let
me know how it turns out for you
[Music]